- The coach who (beep)ed his
wife and (beeped) her too.
I never got to see the first one,
so why are we talking about the sequel?
(piano music)
- Today we're guessing real
versus fake porn titles.
- If my mom is watching this, my knowledge
of porn titles is scant.
- What is porn?
- Porn who? Does she work here?
Pornography in legal? She's a nice lady.
- I think I've searched
"am I addicted to porn?"
like multiple times in my life
- Oh.
- If my mom's not watching, yes,
I've been preparing for
this since I was 13.
- The touch of the cock
- What if this is like a spin on a really
literary novel from the American canon?
(laughs)
- I don't know, I don't know.
- I'm nervous.
- It's too lovely.
- It does have a certain
elegance to it, doesn't it?
- The touch of the cock, this is dumb,
so I'll say it's real.
- I'm gonna say you made it up.
- I'm gonna say fake too.
(buzzing)
- Yeah.
- Adventures in Uranus
(laughing)
- That's just fun.
- That's cute.
- I don't know why, but
I feel like it's fake.
- Here's the thing, I
think straight people
are still a little
weirded out by butt stuff.
It implies extensive insertion.
- He is writing a dissertation
(laughs) right now
- Yes.
- I'm gonna agree with Sheridan on this
and I'm gonna say this is fake.
- This like checks all the boxes for like
punny, parody, exciting.
- I think it's real.
- I say it's real.
Adventures in Uranus is real,
and if it's not real, get
the liscensing done tonight.
(buzzing)
- (yelling) Oh my gosh! We're so good!
- Ah! What?
- White men can't hump.
- You like that one, huh? (laughing)
- I feel like this could
be a straight porn.
This is not a gay porn title.
We don't do clever parodies. (laughing)
It's like tripe X men Wolverine gets
pounded by Bandito. (laughing)
I say real.
- Let's do it.
(chime)
- Of course that was real.
I've got a nose for this.
Forest Hump.
- I think that that's a real one.
Because that is very literal, they are
humping in a forest.
- I want this to not be real, cause that
- I...
- You think it's real?
- I think it's real.
- We're gonna go with real.
- I'm gonna go with real.
- That's true, porn parodies, real.
(chime)
- (laughing) oh my gosh! That's crazy.
Wow okay!
- ET, the extra testicle.
- No!
- No. That can't be real.
Please don't let it be real.
- It's like so crazy
that it might be real.
- I'm gonna go with real.
- That's another like movie
parody, so I say it's real.
- Yeah, I think it's real.
(chime)
- Humanity, no. What
happened to the greatness
and quality of titles
like White Men Can't Hump?
What is this? (laughing)
- Sausage galore.
- (laughing) That's bad. That affected me.
- That's like a gang bang or
a circle jerk or something,
- I feel like it's a
pizza you would order.
- Or a pizza delivery porn.
- I guess I'd say it's real. I'm not sure,
I'm not sure. This is a hard one.
- I don't know, I feel like it could
it could go either way.
- I'm gonna say it's fake.
(buzz)
(laughing) oh my god! That
was greatest right there!
- I wanna say we're
really good at guessing
porn titles, but we're not.
- We're like just barely above average.
- We kicked ass.
- We did really well.
- Wouldn't it have been cute if we got
like 7 for 8
- And like good for them (laughing),
And now it's just like,
do they have a problem?
(cheerful music)
(squeaking)